hey guys and welcome back to but like I
was taking 3 today I'm doing something
which I normally never even do which is
making a station before I actually make
the coaster itself or even the
surrounding area and there is a pretty
good reason why I want to make the
station first which is the fact that
this station is going to serve as the
major weenie
of the German area to put it into what
this needs terms and I think I actually
sort of got that term from King rct3 a
long time ago and I never really gave
him credit for it so quick shout out to
King Marcy t3 but yeah a weenie is
basically that really big structure in
any part of a theme park or the theme
park as a whole that really draws you
toward it and it can be really large or
just be a really beautiful structure but
it's sort of visible from a larger area
of the park and really draws you towards
some certain area and really serves
almost as a centerpiece of a given theme
and for Germany I wanted to make it this
station and actually make it a very much
decorated station and go way beyond what
I normally just do with stations so it's
sort of fulfilling a double role of not
just being quiet importance as a loading
and unloading place for the coaster
itself but also the major part of
scenery for this part of the park and to
basically talk about what type of
building I want to make the station into
it's mostly inspired by a small palace
in a park called tourism Stein which is
where most of the inspiration is from
but it also really generally looks a lot
like Bavarian buildings in general and
consoles and you know I might throw
quite a bit from neuschwanstein in this
entire part of the park as well but yeah
the idea in general is it's going to be
a almost palish almost palace each
building with a lot of timber works and
sort of a lot of details especially on
the tower and that's basically the way
in which I want to
make this work with the surrounding area
and in front of it I want to have this
larger Plaza which might also kind of be
like a bier Garten and have some tables
over there and a small restaurant where
people can drink beer and through German
fashion I suppose and eat sausages and
sauerkraut that is terribly
stereotypical I am sorry about that but
yeah that's the general idea for this
area at least and for a change actually
did want to also add some very simple
interior in the station and obviously
before you actually finish the station
itself it's a lot easier to place every
part of the shape except for the roof
just to be able to play some simple
interiors in and in this case I really
didn't want to do too much especially
since I barely have any experience with
interiors I usually skip them but of
course given that this is a station
that's some extra need to actually get
some good interiors in and since it's
such an important station as well
I really just figured might do it right
now already before I already cover it up
with all the roofs that I'm gonna have
over this thing because I actually do
want to have a double roof for this
building which means that I'm gonna have
a lower layer of wood and above that
have the actual roof which is gonna be
tiled again because I can't quite as
much as I would like to get the medieval
tiled roof that you find often in
Bavaria in because it just doesn't exist
in the game now what you may already
sort of note in the shape of the
building is that it's very much a
building which has a front and a back
it's it's no real excuse to not pay any
attention to the back
I want to detail the back just as much
as the front but it's really a building
which has a facade near the front where
that small plaza is gonna be as well so
the large 1x1 tower on the corner is
going to be the main tower and spire of
the building and this small sort of
protrusion on the front over here will
just be a small roof with a window and
balcony just do you have that decoration
on the front as well and then they stone
with the arches underneath it would just
be a small walkway to add some more
detail and to the building when you're
looking at it from the front of course
so yeah this is where I wanted to add
the roof within a roof idea it's not
typical of Germany at all and
realistically it's really only common in
many Asian cultures for example Japan
but I really wanted to have it in this
case since the issue is where some of
the roofs in roller-coaster country they
have the same texture on the top of them
as on the bottom and I didn't really
want to look at tiled roofs from the
bottom of this thing and would much
rather just have some wood underneath it
so that's why I did want to add a double
roof
so yeah it's purely just to make the
interior look a little bit better but
it's not actually there for any specific
purposes otherwise and just as a quick
tip I guess when it comes to making
buildings in rollercoaster country
you'll know that especially for this
building I placed off the walls first
forgetting about any of the details and
really wanted to get the shape done
right first and this is really what I
would recommend doing especially if you
go for a building which is so present
but also I completely detached from
other buildings and you want to have a
more complex shape of since really I
find it's much easier to just create a
very simple structure of your building
and look at it sort of from a more study
perspective where you can look how it's
gonna sort of work in terms of scale
with the rest of the area because I
obviously didn't know that's before I
started building this building and how
it might look in the end so really
that's why especially for buildings like
these always want to place the walls
first and place them in a very general
shape and not add any details or even a
roof to them and only if you're actually
100% sure you want to go with that type
of shape start adding the roofs and
floors and details to it
which is also what I did in this case
especially since when it comes to the
roofs they are obviously quite simple I
did change them from this right here
since that looked much more
Transylvanian than Bavarian at least
that's why I feel so I didn't want to
quite have that but yeah and this is in
general a pretty simple straightforward
4h roof and it's not going to really be
much else really just want to add a
couple more details to it which you'll
see later on in this video but the only
place where I'll really experiment a lot
with a lot of detail on the roof is
going to be the spire as that's
definitely and generally where most of
the attention is gonna go when it comes
to this building since it's obviously so
central and by far the highest part of
the building which sort of comes down to
another small tip which Kelly got from
Leonidas way too long ago and I can't
remember how long ago it was but a
pretty important point about detail
that's the more detail a building has
generally the better it is but there's
something which you kind of want to keep
in mind especially if you want to go for
a style that doesn't seem overblown or
fantasy like is that detail works best
if it's unevenly spread around the
building so some areas with very heavy
details and some areas with less detail
so for instance Japanese buildings I
don't know why I'm coming back to this
but they have very detailed roofs but
way less detail the walls especially if
you look at their castles and this
building for instance but you'll see
with many German buildings as well is
that they have actually not so detailed
roofs but a lot of detail on the wall so
you have all the timber work going on or
other details like the stone which I
have on the spire or the tower over here
and more decorated windows to always
sort of make sure that parts of the
building are really detailed and other
parts of the building are less detailed
which is what I wanted to try in this
case as well and when it comes to
details too they tend to stick out or
stand out a lot less of course if you
use the same color for all the details
so while I used the same color which is
white for all the brick details and
details around windows just to make sure
that it wouldn't look too awkwardly like
there are too many different colors
still want to get a good contrast in
this building which is why one of the
reasons why I made the wooden frameworks
bread and that very dark shade of red
because it so much sticks out from the
whites and it's such a beautiful
contrast from how lights the rest the
building is and especially in the case
of that little balcony on the little
protrusion there it really makes the
balcony stand out a lot more from the
rest of the building since you can
really have that contrast between the
white details and on the other hand the
very dark red frameworks of wood and the
same sort of goes for the horizontal
beam with which the roof ends which is
like a very visible clear demarcation of
the wall ends here and the roof is gonna
start here and like that actually in
this and another important point was
also that I wanted to make the bottom
floor so the one with all the wooden
arches quite a lot darker which is why I
used a grey instead of white then the
top floor just to make or that there is
this clear distinction between what's
the base of the building which is gray
sort of have as a darker stone edge
texture to it and the top of the
building which is very light and has a
very clear stucco texture to it and the
very top of the building near the roof
where the very Doric rent framework is
going on
I make things sound way more complicated
than they actually are it's just a
simple timber building really but that's
the general idea that went behind it and
what I also found especially in this
case is if you have these little bits of
larger building left I need to place a
roof over them just go crazy with the
roof and place it in two different
directions and maybe add little spires
and things sticking out because nothing
is more boring than a flat roof
especially in the case of such a
building which isn't too
large a flat roof makes it seem smaller
than it really is
which is also what these 4-h roofs help
with a lot to actually make the building
seem quite large where in reality this
building isn't that large in the end oh
and when it comes to the timber frames
there's really not too much that I can
say about that especially when it comes
to the timber frames a religous took a
lot of inspiration from real life
buildings and I would say it's not
really a bad thing to do so in this case
since I just wanted to make sure that
the general patterns that I have in the
wood are quite similar to what you see
in real life so it's really just a
mixture of horizontal beams vertical
beams and some slanted diagonal beams
and there is a load of different
variations of this but generally you
don't find that many places where you
have multiple degrees of slanted beams
so it's really just straight horizontal
and one it's about 60 degrees usually I
think where the slanted beams have to
but don't go too overboard with the
stucco is basically the most important
thing don't get too many different
degrees or inclines of the wooden beams
and also don't be afraid to sometimes
just completely skip over the diagonal
inclined beams since sometimes buildings
with the timber frame works really just
have horizontal and vertical beams which
actually the real life duration Stein
castle that which I very much inspired
this building on actually it doesn't
really have any diagonal beams aside
from just a couple of triangles so it's
definitely something that you do see but
yeah in general this building it's not
that spectacularly innovative or much
anything new but it's really all about
the detail so I born even be done with
this building far from it
in this episode alone and it's really
mostly going to be
sort of impressive as a building as it
stands out a lot in detail from the rest
of the buildings as well which is
probably also something that I may want
to note about the fact that it's a
weenie is that especially how much this
building is a very presence in this area
it also has just a higher level of
detail than the buildings around it
which are much simpler and of course
don't go out of their way to have all of
these different stone details like
multiple corner bricks and or big
pillars and arches decorated like that
now in the front of the building I
wanted to add these staircases just to
make it seem a little bit more like it's
a palace and it is a bit over-the-top
and overblown for a theme park I'd have
to say it's but I do like the way in
which at least connects the building to
where the future plaza is going to be
and having these staircases was also a
really good excuse for just having
another road which is going to interact
with the water a bit and another Road
which sort of curves around this area
and then you still have that area in
between these staircases which I want to
decorate in the future with some sort of
foliage like I think I'll just have
flowerbeds over there which is also a
lot of fun to do so yeah while they are
a bit over the top
perhaps I really just wanted to have
them here to make this area in general
feel a bit more connected to the palace
and not just feel like the palaces its
own sort of thing detached from the rest
of this area from a theme park
perspective though it's really not that
necessary I guess in a way the palace
could just be something cool to look at
but these staircases aren't actually
going to be the functional exit or entry
I will have the entrance and the cue go
into the back of the building just for
the reasons that it allows for a very
long queue that sort of wines around and
interacts with the coaster in the future
and connects to this plaza eventually
and have a exit right here at the front
of the building where you can just ride
out exudates
have a nice overview actually of the
rest of the germen are
and just take a couple of steps and
you're back into the park so yeah let's
the general idea of how this is gonna
work with a coaster I realized I haven't
talked about the coaster itself yet and
that's actually because I have no idea
what I'm really gonna do with the
coaster and that really means well I
think I am going to make it a mine train
that is most of what I know about it but
I have no idea how I'm actually gonna
plan it I want to have a small mountain
around the other side of the river and
have the coaster go through that but
really what type of see if CTR I'm gonna
use for it and what type of layouts I
want to go for I'm really not sure about
it'll be a type of family like mine
train coaster much like thunder mountain
just German / Austrian themed what I
might actually do though is have a small
castle at the top of the mountain just
because it feels like it might just be a
missed opportunity if I don't do so but
even that's I am not too sure about so
when I head back into this area after I
finish the plaza and queue I really have
to get my act together and think a
little bit more about wanted to want to
do with this area so until I really have
a solid plan I'm actually not gonna
touch it either
especially since right now this area is
already quite well planned and in
general I don't really want to quite
ruin that anyway just a few pictures
which I thought I'd add before we
actually go on I keep in mind though
these are still a bit of a work in
progress
I definitely still need to and all the
foliage around it of course which really
should help making it stand out more
flowers in front of it's some details
like the general signs of life from some
street lights around it some benches
some planters especially on that little
floor which is raised above these stone
arches it would be really good to have
some planters over there and maybe some
smaller details that I'll get to in the
future and I'm not quite sure how and
what I'll do with them but yeah this is
basically the basic building and in the
next episode I'll be working on making
the plaza in front of its with a small
flat right
and maybe you start work on the queue
and more of this area with some rock
work and foliage as well of course so
thank you guys for watching and auf
wiedersehen